il suffit d'une minute et tout s'écroule
il était 13 heures exactement tout à
l'heure quand la fameuse muraille de
chine de saint-etienne a été démolie 35
ans après sa construction la barre de
logements hlm de 250 mètres de long
s'est écroulé foudroyé par 700 kg
d'explosifs
récit d'une journée pas comme les autres
reportage
france 3 rhône alpes sans forces de
l'ordre ont été mobilisés dès 8 heures
aux abords de la muraille de chine
rocade fermé quartiers bouclés filtrage
serré petit à petit un périmètre de
sécurité s'installe dans un rayon de 150
mètres
seuls les artifices y resteront au
centre du dispositif pour établir le
poste de tir dans une cage d'escalier
d'un bâtiment voisin
il est 12h 45 et déjà les premières
sirènes annonce le moment fatidique
le temps est presque idéale au dessus de
montchauvet et puis dans un silence
fébrile
une fois le nuage de poussière dissiper
les équipes d'artificiers constateront
le résultat comme convenu la cheminée de
la chaufferie et la pharmacie sont
intactes résultat parfait ou presque
alors les presque parfait c'est qu'il ya
quelques éléments qui sont allés casser
quelques brindilles de façade du bas ce
qu'on appelle le bâtiment b mais qui
n'engendre a rien à ce que les familles
puissent rentrer chez elles puissent
revivre normalement
d'ailleurs vous pouvez voir qu'on est en
train d'arroser le périmètre pour
pouvoir permettre aux gens de leur moins
de toucher impossible après deux tirs
on nettoie site pour le rendre en
sécurité afin que les gens à partir de
ce soir public puisse vivre dans la
tranquillité
il faudra maintenant deux mois aux
entreprises pour déblayer le site
quant aux habitants du quartier il leur
en faudra certainement beaucoup plus
pour effacer cette journée près de
marseille